Elizabeth starts off this hour from
Texas hi Elizabeth how are you hi miss
Granby Harry he didn't get out better
than I deserve what's up well just the
first to give you a little bit of
background at me I the only that I have
there's my home I was raised by a father
who very much galician not having that
so I was able to go to school debt-free
and everything so the only dad I've ever
had as a mortgage I am single but
recently started dating this gentleman
and I do know he has some bed I don't
know how much but I do know he's
mentioned his car payment and I know
he's mentioned student loans and so my
question is just simply looking for
advice on how to breach the subject of
finances and working towards getting out
of debt and why that's so important to
me how old are you I am 34 years old
okay all the same in this 29 okay cool
very nice good stuff well I mean as you
date longer obviously you go into deeper
subjects right so it's a little weird to
start pulling out financial statements
on the first date you know right yeah so
I don't know how long you guys have been
dating but if you're starting to talk
about serious things in life and what
you think about those money would be on
the list and you know I into this
relationship do you feel like you are
well we've been dating for about a month
to talk to fit it could be serious but
we're still getting to know each other
okay well I want to make too big of an
issue of it yet he does know to some
extent my feelings about not having debt
and what he doesn't know is that if we
were to move forward I need him to take
this seriously yeah it's a deal breaker
for you exactly and not say something
feels like a lie but I also don't want
to rush in and overwhelming on it and so
if I'm trying to move your out the best
way to handle that because not
mentioning but this is a deal breaker
you know I hate for him to propose and
then we go oh by the way you've been
dating a month yes
oh yeah we're far away from being
proposed I'm just saying in general
between now and proposal there's going
to be a lot of opportunities you know
for you to bring this up but you know I
think you just occasionally drop the
hint and see if he takes the bait on the
discussion without us having a define
the relationship discussion around money
that a one month into it
right but but you know sometime the next
few months for sure I mean most people
will date on average about six months or
more before they get engaged that will
be the averages and I don't know how
long you know what you guys will do
that's up to you certainly but Rob but
but you know it's just before you move
towards an engagement there's really
four areas you need to have explored and
have some agreement on and because all
the data tells us this on you know
successful marriages if you are in
agreement on these four areas you have a
very high probability of a successful
marriage religion kids crazy in-laws and
family members and money yeah and if you
you know so at what point are you
talking about religion at what point are
you talking about you know the the crazy
people in your family or his family and
and and you know how what kind of
relationships you have with your parents
and that kind of stuff in casual dating
relationship you don't usually go into
you know my dad's a freaking out raging
alcoholic or something you know you know
go out of that you don't say that in a
casual but once you start getting
serious you know that's something he
would need to know if that not saying
that's the case with you I'm just making
up something right point is these are
serious subjects and as it gets more
serious that's the same time frame is
when you'd open up all of these yeah and
we have broached these subjects on some
level they're not as serious as we would
need to eventually but all of these
dozens have been talked about to some
extent except for money not as much so
all of them maybe
my friend a little bit on that and you
could use you could talk about it
through the lens of family like you know
we're talking about my parents the other
day and you know my dad has always been
this anti debt thing and I you know it's
given me a lot of peace to not have dad
and so just bring it up you know but but
you know you can take it where but those
ought to be running at about the same
pace in in terms of you know if it's
serious enough to talk about whether or
not you'd have kids getting married it's
serious enough to talk about money and
it's okay to bring that up and so yeah
but those are things that you ought to
go through in the quote courting that's
an old phrase but during the time that
you're dating these are things you ought
to get to know about each other
that's that yeah so good question
interesting discussion hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]